[Music]
a wave of development is rippling
through the windy and sunny parts of the
united states
in the midwest newer and bigger wind
turbines are ranking the locals
and fights over solar farms have broken
out in california and virginia as well
new research says that if this movement
continues it could stall the country's
green energy transition we used to think
that there's sufficient land
for the wind that is needed
but now we believe that there could be
some land use conflicts that would
actually hit some of the limits to wind
development
the fights about solar and wind are all
about how land is used in several parts
of rural america locals say that the
installations are dominating the
landscapes so these projects are as big
as they are because that's what makes
them as cheap as they are samantha gross
who studies energy security at the
brookings institution says that most u.s
wind turbines are roughly 500 feet tall
and are spaced more than half a mile
apart these installations can be seen
for miles
you have projects being put in place in
those areas where people aren't used to
seeing a lot of development and they're
there because that's where they need to
be
but they can generate public opposition
because they're a real change to the use
of the land
researchers say that it takes at least
10 times as much land to develop
renewables when compared to fossil fuels
well if you think about making
electricity from natural gas and the
kind of land footprint that has
it's about one-tenth of the land area
per unit of power that you have for a
wind facility
you can do other things with that land
you can farm underneath it have it for
pasture land but still that land will be
occupied by the wind facility despite
these land use issues financiers and
leaders in washington are pouring money
into new green energy projects what we
as a country should do is makes smart
sustainable investments
with appropriate financing
to make this nation more productive
to advance america's leadership in clean
energy to win the jobs of the future
while meeting the threat of climate
change the high level of interest in
clean energy is causing controversy as
the rubber hits the road out in the
country
several states in the u.s wind quarter
are grappling with how to deploy more
renewables for the grid
the state of indiana started to
experiment with utility-scale wind power
in 2008
as of 2021 40 of the state's 92 counties
have some amount of wind or solar
development but a groundswell of
activism has taken over county and state
level politics
citizens across indiana have campaigned
against new clean energy developments
arguing that the structures are an
economic scam that will be a nuisance to
public health biodiversity and local
property values
the movement gained influence over the
years as of 2021 more than 30 indiana
counties have restricted the development
of utility scale renewables
many use setback requirements which
determine how far away projects must be
removed from existing properties
this tactic can keep turbines away from
homes which reduces the flickering
shadows and noise created by the
installations
but some residents would like to see the
bans on renewables come to an end there
are folks who are saying wait a minute
my county
lost millions of dollars in tax revenue
state legislators like ed soliday a
republican representing valparaiso
indiana say that the restrictions may
harm the region's economy
in 2021 soliday wrote and introduced
house bill 1381 which would have
prevented counties from issuing outright
bans on wind and solar projects the one
thing we know for sure is there's a
market for
renewable energy
and we can either pay
ever rising transmission costs to buy it
from someone else or we can participate
in the market here in indiana the bill
introduced by soliday died in the
state's 2021 legislative session as
locals push back he says a similar
battle is unfolding over solar energy
that same group that opposed wind has
now come up with health arguments
visual arguments against solar panels
and most of those will not stand up to
peer review
it's important that these projects are
designed to be serving the community as
a whole because if they're not designed
that way it can lead to downstream
flooding
it can lead to
resentment
and therefore antagonism and therefore
opposition to these projects jesse
carbonda is the executive director at
the hoosier environmental council his
group supports renewable energy by the
end of the decade the overall land
footprint of the solar farms in indiana
could be of the size of the entire
indiana state park system
and so how solar farms are designed in
the backdrop of climate change really
matters because they can act as an agent
for
community resilience in the face of more
intense and more frequent flooding or
they could exacerbate it if they're
designed poorly
critics say that the solar farms will
eliminate farmland and could disrupt
natural habitats
similar conflicts have broken out across
the plains of kansas and ohio in the
sunny california desert and along the
windy northern atlantic coast
plans for wind farms in the northeast
were introduced in the 2000s but as of
2021 little had been built beyond a
five-turbine project near rhode island
that didn't keep developers from
pursuing the area biden officials have
given final approval to a 2.8 billion
dollar project to place 84 turbines 12
miles off the coast of nantucket island
researchers at the national renewable
energy laboratory are modeling how these
political battles will affect the
country's energy supply it's very
difficult to capture people within
models the social or human side is
always hard to distill into a set of
equations true mai is a senior energy
analyst at the national renewable energy
laboratory his team's research shows
that the u.s has enough wind resources
to power the grid but the local
opposition movements are starting to
limit the supply of land that can be
used for wind farms when mai's team
modeled out a scenario where populated
counties keep banning renewables
development was concentrated into the
relatively unsettled mountain west
we've never
expected land to be a constraint for
wind and renewable deployment for all
the energy needs that we have but now
that we've looked into this further land
use conflicts is a very important issue
here
experts say that the bans on renewables
will push up the costs of the energy
transition
that's because wind and solar are among
the cheapest sources of energy according
to levelized cost estimates from the
consulting agency lazard
renewables have been deemed critical to
the future of the global economy
but the backlashes unfolding in the u.s
show a latent risk as the green energy
markets heat up
[Music]